hey before this video begins check out
this is happening check link in the
description did you hate how's it going
bro got a new it setup it's pretty cool
look I can do this
2014 pity pot I could do this all day no
it's pretty good I like it I like the
quality I want quality in my videos guys
just understand that this is a sacrifice
for better content we're gonna play a
video game no I know it's been a couple
days
pretty crazy video games this one looks
like it's quite good so let's check it
out it's called Home Sweet Home Alabama
where the skies are so blue that's the
only song I know how to play on a guitar
I would love to play for you
time but not today we're playing this
game my head hurts
mm too much booze last night all right
mate
except my daughters yeah okay I'm up
Jan is that you who what hey Who am I
this is cool hey I thought Jane was here
but never mind I gotta get home
I thought Dane was here I thought oh I
always just judge Harper if eclis all
the judge actor sorry all the voice
actors even though clearly like I'm the
worst [ __ ] what are all these things
always think hey fast lane okay
interesting
flashlight yeah that's not that cool
okay maybe you know the voice acting is
fine but the writing is a bit [ __ ]
alright if I saw a flashlight I'd be
like Oh a flashlight how how
conveniently placed oh gee I hope no one
scares me next this is clearly set up by
Jane looks like I need to find a new
wife you piece of [ __ ] chair you look at
me like that once again and I will [ __ ]
you oh I will alright making my way
downtown where am i I don't I I don't
know how can I get out of here I love
the voice again it's beautiful how could
I get out of here where am I dude you're
about to die [ __ ]
hi is this a Petey game that just goes
around in circles let's find out I see
they're playing jacksepticeye on the
radio no thanks oh okay I need a key
there's key tab description a normal key
for uh no K well thanks for wasting my
time
there we go we did it another creepy
horror chorus chilly in here
creepy makes my nipples hard which is
always good about being Swedish you know
it's one of those perks oh Jesus
you know no no no no no no no no no no
no if you see a creepy guy around the
corner a nice shut the [ __ ] out hear me
shut the [ __ ] up you don't yell you just
you creep around like this wait him oh
[ __ ] I thought it's just a garbage bag
hello run all right
I don't like witnesses go and rest this
is actually creepy Joe that was not me
being scared I just took a breath really
fast because I wanted to shut the [ __ ]
up I don't get scared will push the ass
games I'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm a
Swedish Viking thank you very much I'm
gonna die
I would check here that's like if this
was a horror scenario always check under
the stairs because people will bail wait
there and then you'll walk through and
then they'll sneak up behind you and
you'll get scared shitless all right I
know these things I'm a horror game
expert there was a guy down there let's
not follow wait [ __ ] you're [ __ ] me
over and I don't appreciate it okay
light doesn't work hello mate you know
what it just hit me it might be Santa
Claus and I've always wanted to be that
guy where did she go well Santa has got
a great ass I gotta say man damn where
did she go oh maybe a little bit more
emotions would be kid that's blood
that's that's Angley alright gonna keep
playing now interesting game interesting
game
all right well we got a lot of blood now
it could be cranberry juice so the fact
that he just went to the conclusion that
it was blood without tasting it I find
that a little a little offensive
okay clearly happened here
where's the exit I listen the only thing
that happened here is that you need to
find another day job all right
there we go what's happened here where
are you oh [ __ ] oh my god I think I'm
supposed to run dude that gave me goose
bumps man Jesus cry though I'm getting
too old for this like I can't keep
playing horror games hey you hey yeah
hey yo I ask you something why did you
buy that shirt god
what what happened I think I died again
home sweet home
more like this place look like [ __ ] and
I got a bad offer on this place got him
that's a good joke right hey you oh my
gosh it Hey here we go
oh no we gotta hide I hate cleaning you
goddamn it
can't see me if I make a face it's a
tongue how big I get there you know it's
quite ironic she pissing on the [ __ ]
wall what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
she just piss on my wall that's gonna
say it's quite ironic for the first time
a girl is chasing me she wants she
doesn't want to you know maybe she does
anyway I think we will go through this
urine portal alright that you're
important dancing damn Daniel Am I wait
there's the way out well clearly the
urine portal will set us free so let's
check this out what was that a bucket my
god yeah that'll do the trick
listen you want to build up the scares
you can't just throw a [ __ ] naked
lady at me and then be like look like
like you should have had the bucket
before that's why I can open it try
let's change maybe I can find something
to cut it cut my life into pieces
hey how convenient
I didn't take long I love that about
games as soon as you need something
you'll find it oh [ __ ] she's urinating
she's urinating everyone it's change I
know it's [ __ ] change yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] the urine lady is coming Beach got
him got him
works every time that's Christ [ __ ]
hell
what is happening I'm actually scared
what the hell
that's if I know oh my gosh Stefano
can't believe I'm still [ __ ] play
horror games 2017 everyone Jesus Christ
this can't be healthy okay
I'm [ __ ] okay can you stop peeing on
the walls it's weird
all right which one did she go in I
guess I'll go in this one h-hey are we
back where we were in the beginning what
is happening I'm confused now I guess
I'll take a [ __ ] no well then I don't
know what I'm doing all right
victus kook who did not get scared that
was not a jump scare try not to get
scared a challenge didn't work
that was not me being scared that was me
reacting in a Swedish kung fu defense
thank you very much [ __ ] you you don't
know you don't know our secrets who
keeps a [ __ ] urine in okay I guess
I'm in the air now you know that's
actually pretty smart what happened I
can't can't get out of the Oh
I'm in a urine everyone all right how do
I get out of here
hey took a little take a little bunny
hop there nice okay I suppose we go
suppose we go through here and now if we
run into that [ __ ] we know where to
hide okay where's your missus
oh [ __ ] okay I'm not okay
that's gives me okay it's close 110
okay we're walking in circles now aren't
we cuz this is the bathroom yeah [ __ ]
I'm a bit confused at this point not
sure what I'm I see what's blocking the
way hi hey ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't you just hate when wood is
blocking the wait okay let's just be
careful we can do this hold my hand you
can do this with the lens now does it
look like we're holding hands it's just
a cute lower moment that we're having
together I can't really I can't really
play a [ __ ]
alright listen hold your own [ __ ]
hand what do you want me to say
alright [ __ ] went in here I think
done Mademoiselle but where did that
[ __ ] car what I'm looking for
hey I don't think we've been in here oh
alright alright getting a little scared
cuz it got all quiet all of a sudden
hello hello hello hello
alright how does everyone doing oh okay
well I want to make a period joke but I
at the same time I don't think it's Hey
Hey look at that a strange looking doll
full of nails great promise I will never
do that again and a would of curse have
you ever hated someone so much actually
you know what let me do this in check
septic I voice
have you ever hated someone so much that
you want you suffer agonizing pain this
magic is for you with this you can be
witch nails into the stomach of your
enemy
causing them extreme pain like that this
black magic has been passed for
generation to generation instructions
obtain personal items from our I am born
thank you jack thank you for that
appreciate your input and we still need
an axe
we need an axe and I'm not talking about
dead you're over it haha hey there we go
perfect I'll take that uh [ __ ] [ __ ] be
quiet pull my hand that's my new car
back
okay we're fine Jesus Christ [ __ ]
sweaty hands man where's she going I
wish I had that effect just [ __ ]
colorist doors magically behind me
that'd be [ __ ] cool this [ __ ] all
right now we got to be real real [ __ ]
stealthy because I'm talking alot it's
because I'm nervous all right I'm get
nervous when they say just we can do
this just [ __ ] I just got to think of
something real nice like a really nice
sausage why did I go with that okay
we're fine we're fine
we're gonna live we're gonna live it's a
miracle it's a miracle everyone gonna
live damn it it's gonna get out of here
and I'm gonna start a YouTube channel
where I play only horror games not
[ __ ] smashers smells like rotten
taters in here oh no someone has been
farting freely here this is real [ __ ]
bad
oh [ __ ] it's her how does she keep
teleporting so annoying okay I think we
must be getting real [ __ ] close at
this point come on
I don't know why the tongue thing all
right don't ask come on I can do this oh
[Music]
my god
what's this where she was voodoo
enchantment
more water [ __ ] [ __ ] that hello oh [ __ ]
okay go in go in
no just want to go home
hey I'm fine baby
what the hell oh [ __ ] uh disgusting
disgusting what what is this a circuit
breaker
maybe we just could be the way out this
kitchen
Oh
Oh budgets The Doors jammed the doors
jammed
[ __ ] I'm I got fall okay that's fine
Oh [ __ ] is coming hey it's just coming
back [ __ ] coming back [ __ ] Jesus
disgusting
how does she keep knowing where I am I
don't understand okay we're fine
we are fine she she's just breathing
really loudly might want to get you
might want to get that check honey
okay we're fine excellent bat bat bat
bat bat bat bat bat bat babe how that
did you
peach
now that's [ __ ] right haha
when in doubt scream like a [ __ ] I'm
just full of life advice today guys it's
free it's free it's free it's free don't
worry hold right click and then oh I see
I see okay hello ha brass okay we're did
it alright alright I hear a lot of
breathing action going on over here oh
[ __ ] me jesus [ __ ] christ oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you and they [ __ ]
dick hole why do I say these horrible
things I don't like this I don't like
this at all
come on Felix you can [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] this game why
does she breathe so much okay alright I
know I'm being quiet I'm just kind of
nervous that ass look at that ass boy oh
god you heard me are you doing squats
damn damn girl who's your daddy
I don't know why I asked that I don't
listen relate to anything okay all right
what are we gonna [ __ ]
great all right what what about in here
the creepy toilet the men's toilet I
find that a little bit sexist by the way
that the guys toilet looked like [ __ ]
that's not necessarily true I'm a guy
and I find myself to be very clean in my
[ __ ] thank you very much video games
oh [ __ ] okay I don't want to die now
I really don't okay we just gotta wait
for that [ __ ] [ __ ] a duck don't [ __ ] a
duck that was not a life advice
it was a life hack don't turn don't turn
a job lot of spit does caca
okay we're here now for no reason great
this is it
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] we did it holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] hole this is what we needed fuse
yeah I got it
a fuse yes I've got it hmm okay now we
just got to [ __ ] go back I'm hiding
it's jacksepticeye playing again it's
[ __ ] awesome song [ __ ] up [ __ ] okay
she didn't see me she didn't see me
Oh Oh
coming we're going we're going
everybody's going
everybody say sha la la hey la vez
demand a vote slave leader Britta I do
scaffold for semester I'm a fair far
more trebly I'm gonna trick give me pork
empanada break down so gold is we have
love all that
oh my setting nephew Sentret down and
over there listen I sang a program same
category my orcas and the orderly of my
family
what the [ __ ] am I saying go go go
[Music]
when is this game over
ah [ __ ] she's gonna [ __ ] no I can't
no please don't tell I'll think I I'm
sweating I'm [ __ ] sweating like a
[ __ ] oh we did it we did it partner
thanks for being my special friend
special friend now that I know you now
that you know me oh my god and Ainsley
alright that was a really cool horror
game I really enjoyed it did you like it
let me know in the comments down below I
thought it was pretty cool despite some
flaws but it's a demo so maybe check out
the full version when it's done I know I
haven't done many gameplays but I was
enjoy doing one else like this Resident
Evil 7 is coming out very soon so I'm
definitely gonna be playing that as well
if you enjoy this horror type of stuff
let me know
I appreciate your feedback here's
another video if you want to watch
another one and as always kisses and I'm
just gonna hang around for you [ __ ]
actually click do it great